welcome to MIB the men in black are back
this time Tessa Thompson and Chris
Hemsworth are making those suits look
good we're gonna break down the easter
eggs we found hidden in the trailer
Plus take you back in time to 1996 while
we were on set of the original Men in
Black recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as politically
recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as quickly recognizable
only as deja vu and dismissed just as
quickly Tessa Thompson joins the team
walking into that very same MIB
headquarters with the giant fan and the
obligatory guy reading a newspaper of
course gonna be fun
left fun with it
and then we see some paintings on the
wall and on the right that's actually
agents J and K aka Will Smith and Tommy
Lee Jones in the final battle from the
first movie
and guys the worm guys are back
of course they were what helped convince
Jay to join the team in the first place
but here's my favorite Hemsworth throws
a tiny hammer in a fight at the end of
the trailer is that Thor reference not
the Thor reference only you would catch
that and that's why I love you
this trailer brought up so much
nostalgia for us that we dug into the
vast et vault and of course we were on
set with Will Smith and Tommy Lee Jones
in 1996 you guys are going to love this
check it out he's Will Smith he is the
man in black and we're here on the
world's biggest soundstage right that's
right it's the biggest one on the planet
this is some of the stuff from men in
black right this is the weapons Locker
oh okay you know where we come in here
and we get these are all our weapons you
know this is a intergalactic space
molecular air dispersing hairdryer slap
fist oh yes I'm enjoying all it is
[Music]
well actually what's good about movies
like on such a big scale like you're not
like really the star it's like the movie
kind of the stars like to see this just
this big event you know the movies an
event and your your celebrity just adds
to that rather than the entire weight of
it being on I'm just hoping we get
another new original song because here
come the man is back I think that was he
danced was eight pop let us know what
you guys picked up on in the trailer I'm
a - crossing I'm at Holly underscores
stevis we're gonna dance our way out of
here
[Music]